now it says budget U-turn in a sense
actually it's even more than a U-turn
because Jeremy Hunt went even further
but let me show you first of all the big
kind of challenge that he's faced with
which is this this is the national debt
the higher this is the more the national
debt this is a projection going out into
the future that's what was expected back
in March but look at what the mini
budget did to it you've got that
unsustainable rise in the national debt
and basically what the government's
looking at now are various measures to
bring that down so whether it's spending
cuts or amendments to taxes so not
cutting tax as much as Liz trust would
have initially liked here are those
measures that we learned about today so
corporation tax the biggest one that
saves about 19 billion pounds then
you've got the income tax I'll come back
to that in a second 45p rate quite
interesting it doesn't raise that much
money does it um but nonetheless it does
raise a bit and then you've got various
other measures but income tax that's
interesting because the government went
further it wasn't just a U-turn they've
entirely got rid of Richie sunax plan to
get income tax down to 19p in a few
years time so that's really interesting
but when you say stack that all together
how close does it get to filling that
black hole some people are talking about
because if you want to get the national
debt falling you might need as much as
62 billion pounds a year of a kind of
fiscal squeeze according to the ifs well
here you can see it only gets to about
30 32 billion pounds so there's still a
gap and that Gap is the thing that's
going to have to be addressed in the
future fiscal plan so a lot more still
for the treasury potentially to do but
there was more as well there was the
energy price guarantee that's not going
to be two years this is kind of how much
it might cost for two years we don't
know for sure but it depends on what's
going on a wholesale gas markets for
maybe about 90 billion pounds if you
squeeze that down and reduce it to only
six months look the cost goes down to
about 15 billion pounds so that's a big
saving as well a saving in this case of
about 73 billion pounds put all of that
together and markets were encouraged the
most encouraged I've seen them during
this crisis since a government
intervention and as a result of the
government bond yields going down so too
our expectations for Bank of England
interest rate because these things are
all interconnected back in February I'm
going to give you a recap here they're
expected only to be relatively low then
in August kind of creeping Higher and
Higher by early September the
expectations was that in next year it
was going to go up to about five percent
or so but after the mini budget the
critical difficult thing there was that
went up to about six percent pushing
mortgage rates higher well here's the
good news after this announcement from
Jeremy Hunt it's down to 5.1 percent
that's the lowest it's been since the
mini budget and well it's nice to end on
a little bit of good news